[Music]
this week in feminism
he had a job and then he didn't show up
no I don't
[Music]
remember none of this is possible
without you join the fight and sign up
for mug club today at louder with
crowder.com mugclub for 89 annually join
the fight at Lotto with credit.com mug
club today
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
really well it was I had I made the tea
earlier then I had to warm it up oh and
then I warmed it up too much it's my
fault oh yeah I have no one to blame but
myself and me I added a minute and see
this is the accountability well you also
you the logo is smoldering it is all
right before uh and you know I have to
take accountability because of who we
have in third chair today but I am going
to before that here's the rundown a lot
to get to there are homeless uh homeless
Pirates marauding through the Bay Area
in in California
their words not ours
homeless do we have the photo of the
rundown there you go no that sounds
great yeah I know you're thinking San
Francisco but Pirates you're better than
that come on let's try and build some
real momentum with being an adult here
today uh McCarthy has been ousted as
speaker and I know what you're thinking
does it affect you well not so much
beyond the fact that you spent millions
of dollars to go through this Doug and
pony show and more importantly because
of who we have here in the studio we are
going to do a segment to the ins and
outs the A to Z of Y relationships are
in Decline specifically in the west now
this isn't like a Tupac Biggie East
Coast West Coast thing it's just the
West the western civilization yes which
includes Europe I mean I don't really
know that we should I know but we'll do
it we'll do it just because we feel like
being generous today so my question to
you is what do you think are the biggest
issues um facing people dating in 2020
what are the biggest issues that you've
had to face that you've had to overcome
because in third chair today when you
hear this
[Music]
they're here they're on Rumble and on
YouTube on Instagram at the fresh and
fit podcast Mr fit and or fresh how are
you gentlemen what's up man we're happy
to be here thanks for having us I'm glad
to have you guys hopefully you're set up
because I know you're asking about the
microphones and everything because you
have your own setup yeah and then you
have a notepad
yeah you know just in case I need to
write some stuff what are you writing
now
um hold on I'm right down more than you
are I don't know I don't know who's
writing notes I'm writing notes I'm
writing notes ready I'm writing yeah
what did you say I'm writing why women
deserve less okay well this is not just
true I drew a wiener oh my goodness
so we got it's Myron and Walter right
yeah yes for people who but you know
what we're going to call you Mr fresh
and fit that's how people know you yeah
which one is which then I mean because
that I mean which ones fit which one's
fresh now we're both fit right someone
there you go you're both fit yeah they
were doing pull-ups before the show they
were yeah we're trying trying after they
signed the waiver
I signed that thing so quick I was just
like oh yeah they're like you got to
give all your money
oh my God crap all right so sign the
waiver that says however you hurt
yourself we don't care now
number two CEO and the whitest guy in
the studio Gerald hey how are you
I'm doing well how are not technically
true it's absolutely well the North Matt
over here probably is a little wider
than I am you're 23 and me came back
reparations that's what it said I don't
believe in that it just came in with an
IOU
had to hang on to that one blonde hair
blue eyes you are the kind of person
blonde hair blue eyes not my fault right
okay I did not
use a stuff of Al Sharpton's nightmares
all right but I don't like him so that's
fine and by the way of course uh uh
fresh and Fit I might say fit and fresh
I know it's fresh and fit but I might
reverse it by accident you guys are on
Rumble right people can go and subscribe
to your show Absolutely which is one of
the few shows you also do it live often
yep that's you know without a net that's
pretty pretty scary for a lot of folks
and you kind of specialize in
relationships yes yeah and uh BS going
on in the west with you know intersexual
Dynamics most of improvement the gym
getting your money on point just being a
more attractive guy in general yes give
the truth yeah there you go yeah so yeah
exactly and that's uh that's in short
supply these days so I say that because
Rumble they understand it oh yeah Chris
Chris pavlovsky the CEO he loves you
guys every time we talk he's like I'm
like look Chris I do work too
so uh if at any point I say that you see
this if you're watching on YouTube
[Music]
head on over to rumble that's the
YouTube dump so you guys can say
whatever you want yep and then someone
just hits that dump button and it'll
still broadcast on Rumble yeah we do the
same because it's like oh we're gonna
say something crazy we call the shadow
realm oh but they're on YouTube like
we're going to Shadow realm yeah you
guys got to come on over there Rumble
man shout out to rumble that's where you
show up on techno music plays and you
meet uh reptile that's right I was about
to say thank you very much it's very 90s
video games of you all right so let's
lead with this before we get to the
homeless marauding but pirates in
California let's get to uh there's a
tick tock video here of uh an influencer
now some people would say you know um
gold digging Harlot I would ever say
that though
but that's more accurate that's what
some people would say some people would
call her a gold digging but I
would never say
why is Donald Trump Janice I'm just
saying other people would say that and I
say that's not nice but then they say
she is so maybe maybe
uh here's the advice that's and you can
expect more of this on fresh and fit
podcast but here's the advice that this
tick tocker has for women on how to
enjoy dating now for the past couple of
years I've been the girl dating athletes
let me tell you four simple things I did
to completely change my dating lifestyle
and make me love dating again number one
no simple dates that means no bar dates
no dinner dates no coffee dates no Park
dates I need experiences and I'm trying
to date multiple people gone multiple
dates during the week I can't be
drinking every night I live in New York
and I'm spending all last month in Miami
and I was talking this down hinge match
with him in New York he lives in New
York he flew down to Miami to take me on
a couple dates and one of the dates was
take me to the Everglades like an
Everglades tour and then drop you off in
a gator Pond but at least I'm gonna have
a fun experience to show for it and it
was am I worthwhile rule number two
crazy eyes an expensive woman if you
can't afford me keep it push it
furthermore I'm never paying for a date
I'm not gonna pay your bills so why am I
paying for a date I'm fine you sign the
freedom to me okay people tell you your
standards are too high
they aren't
this is after one date
I love dating this is why well call us
back in eight years when you go ring
ring eggs oh they're not answering now
I love it she's like I'm an expensive
date it's like oh Sherry's Berries let
me take my top off I mean
roses how did that happen yeah this is
the advice that you're giving to young
women look and this is the thing the
whole self-love culture it's shallow
look you're never going to find
self-esteem through these shallow let's
be honest it's objectification a minute
it was semi worthwhile uh because he
took me somewhere nice how did he feel
about it you know we used to talk about
hey Motley Crue had all these whoever it
is and certain whoever here you know
Mick Jagger though he slept with David
Billy which was weird probably he
whoever his son was won the my dad's
cooler than your dad contest yard Mick
Jagger but we used to talk about hey
well what about the what about the
groupies right you're using women we say
it was objectification of women what
about the men do you think that that guy
just thought oh she's just seeing me
because I'm sending her some tips treats
ah this if this this kind of stuff
pisses me off because she's taking
advantage of the system she's just
basically using guys to have experiences
at this point and she's like I don't
want to find dining or anything and she
said five star by the way there's no
five star the Michelin goes up to three
stars you're an idiot and you're just
saying a little bit I'm in the lion
world I understand these things I know
it's but it's like I need experiences
that way at least if I don't like the
date I've got the experience now it's
like yeah you're never gonna find
happiness honey the other thing with her
which you know this is woman needs
basically and I translated some of it
for you all oh did you yeah basically
what she says no simple dates what what
she's basically saying is that I don't
go out with guys that I like that much
so I need to make sure I get some kind
of benefit from going out with you okay
I'm gonna be able to get an experience
so this tells me also she said oh I go
oh guys on hinge that's a lie she's
going on sugar sites she just doesn't
want to admit that on Tick Tock and come
off as a gold digging 304 because the
fact that she's dealing with guys that
are going to fly down to her buying her
roses taking her on these extraving
experiences nine out of ten times she's
gonna meet these guys through a sugar
site there you know have more money Etc
so she's going out guaranteed with older
gentlemen she doesn't find that
attractive that she doesn't like that
much but she wants to be able to help go
ahead and get gifts and get some kind of
benefit which you know a lot of girls do
this they go out with guys that they
don't like that that much for ulterior
motives while they have the guy that
doesn't pay anything they're smashing
him and they're making these other
suckers pay for things making them wait
extracting resources from them and
they're hoping oh my God I'm going to
get laid at some point but a lot of the
times they don't or they get started for
sex see I and he wrote all that down
very quickly
oh one other thing too
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
Girls Just Want to Have Fun yeah that's
the extreme of it I want experience this
over love that's crazy right but right
that's reality now with her it was two
girls just wanna and you guys would be
shocked at how common this is with like
you know she's not even like that hot
like she's pretty attractive but like
average women get these types of
experiences and are able to date this
way where they're able to openly extract
resources from men and not give anything
in return and by the way it's also
self-harming because then at a certain
point they go oh wow I've lived a hollow
life look you know you I always say that
A Christmas Carol is the Fifth Gospel
because Ebenezer Scrooge and it applies
and you're thinking oh Old English white
guy who cares no it applies to you this
was a rich man like it was a liberal at
one point he said are there no prisons
are there no poor houses right you just
said I'll let the government take care
of it and then he realized that What
mattered in life was family was
relationships right he was a second
father to Tiny Tim he was as good of a
father as there ever was it was a man
who said all of these things that I
thought mattered and in that case it was
money in that case it was wealth like
this woman is talking about changed when
he realized the value of family now in
that case there was Redemption because
he was too old to have a family but he
became a father to another young man who
he could help that's where you find
fulfillment and self-esteem and look as
funny as it is because this is a dumb
person it's also really sad and it
doesn't help anybody Gerald I just I
need to ask the dumb question of what is
a 304 woman oh so with the old graphing
calculators if you or calculator in
general if you put like three or four
flip it upside down again it means ho so
we would oh it's a way of kind of
staying YouTube somewhat friendly you
need to stay YouTube friendly yeah but I
used to I spent remember how expensive
those graphic calculators were like 250
dude it's so expensive it's so expensive
to spell boobs upside down the Texas
Instruments
zero eight yes Woman by the way you know
if you call Tech Support to Texas
Instruments you got Vivek ramaswamy
really
so we're gonna go back to this because
we have a whole segment on Western
Civilization relationships but before
that right now they're actually a
marauding homeless pirates in San
Francisco not to be outdone by the
people crapping in the streets it's
because of leftism worked hey San
Francisco would be the place to be that
brings us to this week's Golden State of
crime
[Music]
all right so this is an actual clip yeah
in a new twist
California crime
homeless Pirates
I didn't even know that was a thing how
do you do this this is how they're
describing it in the news homeless
Pirates I mean all Pirates are homeless
technically right they're sort of their
boats I mean they're just they're just
roamers right they're ship Marauders
anyway here's the thing they're actually
pillaging boats
in the Bay Area here's a clip from
shipwrecks to Sunken shipyards
littered in trash
Oakland Estuary
covered in graffiti abandoned and trash
dilap says over the past few months
Pirates have been attacking vessels at
five different locations along the
channel from boats to masts the problem
is sticking out right in front of the
U.S Coast Guard Island oh it's Mutiny on
the booty now the Oakland the Oakland PD
just so you know yeah Oakland uh they
only have one officer they have one
officer trying to operate they have a
boat they have a police boat they're
surrounded by water and one officer
that's like what are you the Canadian
Navy you don't have more to protect the
waterways around the entire city and uh
there's actually a sentiment uh that
they were this is there's another report
the guy who's known as Captain Taylor
they can't handle what they're what they
can't handle on land and you know
financially in resource-wise they can't
so they can't there's no Oakland Navy
you know I'd like to so Taylor and his
fellow captains do all they can to keep
an eye on each other's boats and run off
any Pirates who may show up which in his
view has a nice ring to it but I'll I'll
go with I think it sounds cool you know
anyway just to say that we have Pirates
around here since the Raiders are gone
we only have nuts still hold on to that
one it's like
um so yeah let's uh let's go with
pirerson but can we interview someone
can we interview um if Rob Dyrdek
performed fellatio on a meth Palace
[Laughter]
they're actually uh coming to it on CNN
well they're talking about right now on
CNN are they oh it's yeah oh there it is
let's bring it up man breaking news
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
California is a failed Society man the
fact I used to work in law enforcement
and the fact that they have to bring in
the U.S Coast Guard to deal with that
tells you how much the state is failing
when they don't even have a Marine
Division for a police department that is
right on the water yeah I know common
theme crazy you guys saw that common
theme they're all black
no some of them are just gay white guys
I think Dave Chappelle this is a long
time ago he had that bit where he's like
black people you don't get to run a city
anymore why Detroit and Oakland you what
that's it
and now I mean you know it's every city
so I love the guy though that was
fighting it at the end he's like yeah
I'm fighting we're trying to help our
friends out but since the Raiders are
gone I guess it's kind of cool yeah yeah
exactly yeah they revolved around the
Raiders yeah this is unhealthy by the
way if you sent in actual Lara Croft
Tomb Raider no one would no one would
even notice her in that area of town and
she's like what let's go back to the
Folsom Street Fair find me a bearer now
but cars everyone's talking about this
by the way hit the like button if you're
watching on YouTube because it helps
with the algorithm or on Rumble um but
go over and watch on Rumble and today
with mug Club it's gonna be a lot of fun
with Mr fresh and or fit
um we have an intervention with Gary
later we do yeah everyone is talking
about McCarthy being ousted as Speaker
okay that happened all right does it
affect you not all that much uh but
there are some issues at play here that
I think some people have overlooked so
let me just brief brief you on this if
you've been living under a rock or if
you've been marauded by San Francisco
butt pirates and so yeah without power
yesterday Matt Gates
um succeeded in his effort to uh get rid
of Kevin McCarthy and he's out as
Speaker of the House on this vote
the yeas are 216. the Nays are 210 the
resolution is adopted without objection
the motion to reconsider is laid on the
table the office of Speaker of the House
of the United States House of
Representatives is hereby declared
vacant
that is did you hear that that is the
weakest gavel sound I've ever heard do
we have another we have another clip
where we we we enhance the audio yes
is hereby declared vacant
but by the way this is a lot of this is
Kabuki theater but do you know that
actually how much this cost this whole
process cost you just that the vote two
million dollars at least what just the
minutes that the vote took place two
million dollars I'm sure you could give
an estimate that's higher all the
references we make available at live
with credit.com just so you know Link in
the description that's the issue they're
going to bring in someone else will he
be better probably not maybe a little
bit I'm not a McCarthy fan I don't think
the politicians Should Be Your Heroes
it's just everything costs so much money
and very little gets done absolutely and
by the way this guy barely got in there
anyway it took like 15 votes or
something like that for him to actually
do it and it was 12 30 in the morning
but they finally traveled him in but
don't worry I mean they're gonna help
the Pirates man yeah that money yeah
they really you know what that would
your speaker is ours now it belongs to
me
McCarthy was so pissed by the way he
pulled a fire alarm on the way out yeah
the sign was he was an exit thing like a
button press here to get out so uh Matt
Gates and actually we did we we do
confirm that we we have them on here in
a little bit okay good so that's why we
were a little bit late today also and
also uh just so you guys know we're
blacks or black people yeah yeah is what
it is man sorry man we refer it to we
refer to it as Canadian time I was in
the service industry
kind of if you're a server out there
you're a waitress or a waiter you know
you know when you know what we're
talking about uh here is Gates though
summing up why McCarthy was ousted Kevin
McCarthy couldn't keep his word he made
an agreement in January regarding the
Way Washington would work and he
violated that agreement we are 33
trillion dollars in debt we are facing
2.2 trillion dollar annual deficits we
Face a d dollarization globally that
will crush Americans working class
Americans Kevin McCarthy is a feature of
the swamp he has risen to Power by
collecting special interest money and
redistributing that money in exchange
for favors now I want to go to jail then
and and I I like what he's saying I
think that McCarthy is kind of a little
bit of an empty suit but this is like
buzzword every election
swamp uh people my blah blah narrative
pretty much I mean that's why we say
like it doesn't matter this is the first
time in history that this has happened
so it is kind of a historic event
obviously but sure standard but are we
going to get somebody markedly different
I don't think so but the interesting
thing being floated right now is Donald
Trump I speak because here's one thing
you need to know anyone can be made
speaker I didn't know that I thought it
had to be somebody and that's just you
know my ignorance on this I had no idea
I don't know fresh fresh and or fit knew
that as well but did you know they can
pretty much make anyone speaker I did
not know that no see it's education
that's crazy though even Hitler well I
mean if they had a DeLorean probably
they could bring it you probably have to
be a U.S citizen there's probably at
least that or you know you snuck in our
deck is out of control awesome
my plan is
[Laughter]
pizza but how much would that his
Democrats off it for in some way Donald
Trump became Speaker of the House for
just as like a temporary thing oh my
gosh he just walked he just walked back
in just what you thought it was safe to
go back in the house Daddy's back he had
a high and tight I did this because it's
a house party right house party you're
fine I slept with you that's right
sue me
that's right you already you're lost
ah anyway uh so we do we have uh I
actually so we actually do okay as much
as you know he probably doesn't like
that intro um we do have politicians on
the show we have a lot of guests on the
show and it took us a while to wrangling
down we've been exclusive uh right now
do we have them on the line yep all
right it's time to go to our guest uh Mr
Matt Gates
[Music]
foreign
Mr Gates thank you for joining us
Stephen thank you for having me yeah the
framing is a little bit tight can you
move back a bit we can only see your
forehead that's all we can see uh how's
that uh Mr representative Gates move
back some more we can only hear for it
still yeah
yeah um no I can't I can't move back any
further just just zoom out okay it's
zoomed out all the way how is that even
possible how is that's not a there's no
why don't you zoom out
I don't know I no I can't zoom out even
try backing up your camera
I can't back up my cam it's your camera
did that work okay toolman just cut it I
just I can't even do this
go go
[Music]
jeez sorry I'm sorry guys you deserve it
better yeah it's all good man
second time you know we all have
technical difficulties yeah it is a sick
puppy
I know
I'm a child
my time is worth more than that so uh it
looks like Republicans may even have to
look for a Democrat for a consensus
candidate so again that's the problem
it's like okay the devil you know uh and
apparently though Matt Gates is making
Headway Reaching Across the aisle to um
fill the hole
that is absolutely 100 not doctored her
brother is pissed yes yes
do I get the Rocks yes I'm gonna get the
Rocks now
it's almost like Arnold that's Elon
Arnold
I begged my brother
you know she married her brother right
you guys know that oh she married her
brother there's the marriage certificate
and no one talks about it yeah yeah she
married her brother Haram yeah what the
heck no she she was in his Harem yeah oh
there you go she was one of many sisters
wow yeah oh we can bring it up we've
talked about the show a lot but it's bad
you know look who would you like to see
a speaker you can comment on that and uh
you know let's also put out a poll Eddie
gates in Illinois they'd make a cute
couple now
run for McCarthy over the past nine
months uh and even though sometimes we
see people as you know allies sometimes
we're the adversaries sometimes
Frenemies we always want to honor them
um speaker McCarthy it is time to close
no persons
haven't received a majority of the whole
number of votes cast by surname
speaker has not been elected it's the
honorable Kevin McCarthy of the State of
California has received
216. time to close
endings and beginnings
pretending and beginning now look at
this there's finger pointing going on
Matt Gates is pointing it at uh McCarthy
a crowd is gathering around them he's
walking away
somebody's holding somebody back look at
that oh somebody just held somebody back
Stephanie just look at that it looks
like a fight breaking out on the floor
it says he's coming for you can you
survive yes I'll survive only because he
wants to take this motion so be it bring
it on let's get over with it and let's
start governing if he's upset because he
tried to push us in a shutdown and I
made sure government didn't shut down
then let's have that fight and we now
want to go to representative Kevin
McCarthy speaking after he was ousted as
Speaker of the House I will not run for
speaker again
I'll have the conference pick somebody
else
I hope you realize that every day I did
the job regardless whether you
underestimated me or not I wanted to do
it with a smile
know that it's time for things to close
I know that is time for things to close
[Music]
yes his tenure was 2023 to also 2023.
damn I mean at least he wasn't a 95 year
old you know
for us you know the squirrel that was on
Coke can at the thing with Nancy you
remember that when Donald Trump someone
can pull that clip you guys like that
when Donald Trump was giving his
speeches
like she was testing every single
perfume at the Dior counter
same person that's the point
all right and by the way again just for
people who are tuning in now where's the
best place for people to watch you guys
and uh watch watch your show support you
for us man.com fresher fit and we're on
YouTube as well and what does your Show
air like you have a specific uh Monday
Wednesday Friday 6 p.m we do our daytime
show whether it's money Mondays
womanizer Wednesdays or calling show
Friday and then we do that after our
shows with the crazy bimbos at night
time okay funny after this we're gonna
fly back to Miami and do a show right
away really oh well good maybe she can
uh maybe she can catch a ride with you
that lady
I wasn't really interested in him but he
had a nice plane it was an experience
yeah they had good treats they had good
treats in the plane pistachios I don't
like to Shell them it's too much work
oh my god he has money he has money yeah
more money please more money please so
give me the ring this brings us to the
decline of relationships in the west and
uh these gentlemen speak about this a
lot but it is an issue I think look I've
talked about this before
um yesterday for example when everyone
was talking about McCarthy and then we
had a higher of lives of tick tock on
and we realized that Twitter had
demonetized words and there was some
censorship going on that's the kind of
thing that that I find most important
because speakers come and go as you see
2023 to also 2023
McCarthy
um the kinds of issues that affect you
every single day and the foundation of
society right politics is is is uh
Downstream I've heard Downstream or
Upstream it's Upstream from culture and
the most important component of our
culture is strong relationships and
strong families and that has been
um kind of circling the drain for a
while now and there are a good number of
reasons for that so I want to break it
down for you let you know kind of what
what the causes are and then the
symptoms that people are experiencing
Because by the way a lot of the time
you'll get some people say oh like fresh
and fit oh they must be misogynistic
they must hate women no no this affects
women and men negatively the problem is
that it's been spearheaded
um well by feminists but ironically not
only feminists but the porn industry if
you go back to the 60s and 70s as well
they were often one and the same and now
it's ended up in this Unholy amalgamate
that has left everyone miserable so this
clip really got us thinking to jump off
uh with about modern relationships and
uh dating in America
10 out of 10. but she has a higher body
count than you oh I don't care Vibes I
knew you're gonna say that seven
thousand bodies that just shows that
you're secured because any answer if
your guy will be back I can't do it it
has nothing to do with me until you how
am I going to judge a person based on
the past I wasn't a part of is that
to a judge hey he skinned nine people
alive and ate them I wasn't there yeah
it wasn't my fault she's pretty I didn't
see nothing
so let me give you a few stats here to
undergird this all the references are
available and then we'll open the photo
discussion so uh modern dating in
America okay let's go through young men
first okay in 2023 63 of men under 30
are single okay 34 of women under 30 are
single now if you compare that to 1980
that was 24 of men were single 41 of
women were single so that number has
switched first off it's gotten higher in
both categories but it's also switched
here where you saw there were more women
who were single back in the 80s than
today now today only 50 percent of men
are even actively seeking a relationship
right women find 80 percent of men below
average in other words there are more
men now who are single than women that's
a huge switch there are more people
overall who are single half of men say I
have no desire to change uh from being
single and then 80 of women are saying
well most men aren't worth me uh ending
my life of singlehood that means that
you're not before we get to marriage
you're not going to have meaningful
relationships and people are having
fewer meaningful relationships than ever
before so let's start this off with the
causes okay where this started uh and I
don't know do we yeah we don't have a
okay so let's go back then okay no fault
divorce is number one that's one of the
causes here a lot of people don't know
about no-fault divorce how it changed
um a lot of people don't know where it
came from so Hugh Hefner and Dr Kinsey
you know the guy who said that everyone
should be able to have sex with
everybody uh his Playboy Foundation they
were the first to actually underwrite
legislation on no fault divorce okay and
they were supported by a lot of
feminists now the reason the reason for
this just to be clear is before no fault
divorce there was a fault it was either
cheating abuse or abandonment meaning
that if someone cheated or if someone
physically abused someone they had to
pay right it's not as though there were
no consequences and if there wasn't
cheating or abuse then it constituted
abandonment all were considered a
Breaking of the contract that then
switched in 69 in California the first
note fault state actually Ronald Reagan
he said it was one of the biggest
mistakes that he's ever made no fault
divorce where it just said you can leave
and break the contract for any reason
and there's no one at fault so just to
be clear before that it didn't mean that
you could just cheat at will as a man or
a woman but let's be honest they were
more concerned about men and leave
scot-free now if you cheated you broke
that contract now we need to be clear
about this too the reason that Hugh
Hefner and people on the extreme left
the pornography industry were Pro no
fault divorce is because they actually
wanted men to to live consequence free
and be able to cheat and not have to pay
out half and then it morphed into you
know what the primary earner pays out
half so number one is no fault divorce
number two is feminism okay 1970s three
feminists
um or sorry there were three feminist
books that were written by three
prominent feminists but um there were
three books that really kind of just
ruled the bestseller list one was Kate
Miller's sexual politics one was
Jermaine Greer's the female eunuch and
then the other one was um fire Stones
the dialectic of sex now these uh books
railed against the nuclear family and
they told young women that hey you'll be
free if you are more sexually
predatorial we now have birth control
isn't it great go forth and no being a
better man so that's what happened
women thought that it was going to be
their Liberation and now you see plenty
of videos like this on Tick Tock or on
Instagram where these self-professed
liberal women they have this cognitive
dissonance and they don't know how to
figure it out this clip is sad but
hilarious
oh there it goes do you want to know one
of the saddest realizations I recently
had this one yeah was that as a liberal
woman it is really hard to find a man
who was willing to play the more
traditional masculine role in the
relationship in today's day and age who
is not a conservative a man who wants to
pay on the first date who wants to open
your door who has that want and desire
to take care of you and to provide who
was not a conservative and obviously as
a liberal woman I do want to be
respected from my Independence and I do
want to have my own autonomy
Independence but I don't go dutch to the
traditional female Homemaker child
bearing role and most of the men that
I've dated who do have that more natural
provider masculinity about them are
normally conservative so I don't really
know what to do because I don't want to
compromise my morals and values just to
find a man but am I asking to have my
cake and eat it too yes yes well thank
we're not in the Fret fat Pride
territory so you know it's just it's
allegorical incredible but uh let me I
want to talk to the people who are and
we'll take your chats afterward hey has
this made your life better single people
out there do you believe that your life
is better now
um do the way that we've changed the
dating pool the current environment
really quickly some consequences that
are incredibly severe you know we talked
about people who are not interested in
relationships but since uh these changes
and again it goes back to no fault
divorce feminism and porn these these
were all the Same by the way they were
tied together it was Pro porn Pro sex
and no fault divorce okay now the
divorce rate in the country uh the 50
divorce rate is kind of a myth though it
has gone up women initiate 69 of all
divorces just to be clear and infidelity
and physical abuse are not even the top
five reasons listed marriage rates are
at their lowest point ever and uh then
we'll get into you know before we get to
marriage the reason that people are just
checking out of the dating pool for
serious relationships uh whatsoever I
mean you guys talk about this a lot and
I think a lot of people think well why
is this happen it's not that confusing
when you actually look at the
environment yeah um Bridal companies are
actually like going out of business now
too really yeah yeah we did an episode
on it yeah I thought it was a license to
print money it used to be yeah it used
to be yeah it used to be one of those
industries that was one affected by the
economy because people waste money on
stupid yep yeah ten thousand dollar
dress yeah that's yes say yes to it I'll
fit in it for one day and then blow up
afterwards I can still wear my tux
um now what are you about to say yeah I
just want to add as well um the question
is how do you destroy a country
um that's great yeah and it's destroying
the family first and I think what I want
to add here is about social media played
a huge role in this because once again
Tick Tock is spreading a propaganda
where they push women to be independent
be that woman you see early on let's
take off videos and then men are
becoming less like men so it's kind of
like this whole culture of being in
Social in the world and what's happening
destroys the whole family completely
yeah yeah and you you had to now on the
head with a lot of the problems like I
pretty much was writing down I was like
the feminism leaves birth control which
then leads to sex without consequence
which then leads to divorce then that
destroys the family and then on top of
that to compound the issue you add in
social media just like fresh was saying
women have more options than ever before
right so when women have a lot of
options and they feel that there's a
bunch of suitors that can uh take care
of them or they believe so oh even
though they because women make this
terrible mistake of thinking
[Music]
they all have this crazy mindset where I
have a bunch of guys in my DMs yeah so I
have a bunch of options so I'm gonna go
ahead and play the field and do what I
need to do which is where you end up
with women like that girl before where
she has guys that are going to go ahead
and give her these experiences these
dates
um these situations that she might not
necessarily be able to afford herself
Maybe
[Music]
recharge strength
we need a stronger poll because I keep
bending it no so I don't think that's
what that means but yes here's some of
the consequences by the way like you're
talking about we have we have these
numbers we'll make them available to you
know the body counts as people talk
about the promiscuity right women
control access to sex they're taking
advantage on dating apps like Tinder men
swipe right just so right's the good
thing yeah right means that hey I like
this person okay men swipe right far
more often than women women swipe right
only five percent of the time men 53 of
the time wow
not a good place to find meaningful
relationships yeah to sort of put a face
to it an altered face to it social media
influencer uh and this uh I guess she's
a fitness model uh Brittany Renner oh
man and by the way fitness model from it
just means you know you're just not fat
that's one thing too when women say like
you have no idea what it's like to have
these body centers they were doing
pull-ups before the show like do you
have an idea how hard it is to be lean
and muscular it's like just just don't
just don't be test holiday and guys will
find you attractive so Brittany Renner
who's a fitness model uh made internet
waves talking about her body count on
the bus confessions podcast oh that's a
good sign
so you said your account is 35 okay how
do you feel about that number it's kind
of like annoying because at least
half of my list of one time
oh okay so I but I still have to wear
those you know what I mean it still
happened you know but I think that's the
only thing that's annoying is the music
is annoying that's my number and I I
can't even have on a regular basis it's
usually quarterly like that's kind of
been my schedule unless like a tax
relationship or you know talking to
someone you know that pre-commitment
phase which has not been anything
recently
um yeah it sucks so over half my
probably about half of my list one time
so how bad are you in bed now getting
rid of
well that's Alum that's a moral idea
yeah the moral consequences like
that
at a certain points you
so many of the people that I slept with
yeah didn't come back for seconds yeah
they're if they're not living with a
smile on their face you're doing not
that complicated and for men yeah I want
to mention too
um do women ever tell their robot
account just I mean oh I don't think so
right we never really have an equation
it's actually multiplied by seven add
another ten yep then divide by one well
what are these women Roadies for Van
Halen what was that lighting clerks when
he's at yes and I will say this too
because we actually uh spoke with her on
academics podcast and I predicted this I
told her yo you're gonna have a very
difficult time finding a guy because
you're out there on social media you've
banged a bunch of athletes and
celebrities guys aren't going to take
you seriously yeah and since you're
famous and you make a certain amount of
money you've basically ostracized a
majority of men from taking you
seriously you're probably gonna end up
single and the thing is she's starting
to realize that now yeah you know you're
you're absolutely right and uh you know
I don't think we need to run another
clip of her because we get we get the
point she likes she likes sleeping with
guys they don't like sleeping with her
now I slept with three in one day though
I think that's a that's an important
note you want to have to run the clip
I'm just saying before you feel bad for
her yeah she did the Hatchery maybe yeah
three in one day and here's the thing
you know you guys uh do this Monday
Wednesday Friday you said your show yes
and Nick depalo's on mug club uh every
day at 5 00 p.m and the reason we
brought him on is you know first off
he's the OG if you ask other people in
the industry and say oh yeah Nick Nick's
the guy he's as funny as they get he's
been talking about this for a very long
time now again he's not I'm not saying
that he's a Christian conservative he's
uh he's an agnostic you know Rough
Around the Edges guy but he talked about
the idea of women's body count and even
the sort of secular idea that hey you
want to test drive a car right some guys
would say that this is from 20 something
20 something years ago at least Nick
depalo discussing this issue you could
be the biggest for the first 30
years of your life the NBA west east and
south
if a girl scout when you're 76.
they tighten the vagina and you're
deceiving men when you're doing that
it's like rolling back the odometer on a
used car foreign
[Applause]
plastic that's a road thing man like it
is well we know girls that are in my
lifestyle and literally they'll be
pretty much with basketball players
football players and then they go into
surgery he's like oh I'm a new body now
I'm like no you're not you're still the
same person and it's interesting that he
said this 20 years ago before the
explosion of social media it's even
worse now because a regular girl will
get DMS from athletes celebs guys that
are top tier and they have access to
them now because the internet yeah so
and Instagram yeah no and the thing is
like people say oh you're being Auntie
no look being anti-womens Liberation
meaning having sex with as many people
as you want it's not anti-woman ask ask
how uh go go take a sampling right pull
60 something year old woman and ask them
if they say hey I wish I wish I slept
with more guys one time in my life
that's my biggest regret no almost
always these people say when they're
older they say I wish I would have spent
more time with my family they don't tell
you you don't get I wish I had more
money they say you don't get more time I
wish I had more time that's what the
invariable you say when they say time
they mean time with people that matter
and think about this you're wasting so
much time in your life with things that
don't matter people that don't matter
and the problem right it's a
double-edged sword is you may never be
able to find that relationship that
matters because people are checking out
they're all terrified men are saying
well I don't want to get married because
70 percent if they're college degrees 80
divorces are filed by women just because
and it's no fault and I don't want to
marry a woman who's trained herself her
whole life to learn how to break up with
men and then women are saying hey I
don't want to marry these man Childs men
children sorry it's hard when you
combine the two uh who are going through
second Adolescence in their 30s and and
this is look you want to destroy a
society from within it's tell people
that evil is good and when I say evil I
mean
learning to you know I had a pastor one
time give me this now just like sticky
tape where you said every time you rip
off the tape it gets less and less
sticky yeah this is nowadays to use in
youth group and it's true the more
Partners you have yeah you get really
good at breaking up with people you get
really good at learning to end
relationships that's not great for
yourself long term if you want to be in
a permanent relationship you also get
really good at learning how to get
somebody in bed that's not the goal of a
relationship right if you if you want to
learn how to get a guy in bed it's
pretty simple right the girls don't have
to do a lot of training on that say yes
yeah exactly guys
that's not what you want for a
relationship like that's not the skill
that it takes to be in a relationship
and really you know we've talked about
this on other shows like we do need to
bring some shame back like I'm shaming
the guys that are doing this too and
shaming the women like this is I'm doing
it for your own good you need to be
ashamed of doing these things she was
you could see it in her face like when
she was saying this like I still have to
wear that and I'm like yeah we are you
at 40 telling you now not to make those
mistakes because at 40 you're gonna
regret it yeah and you can't make your
mind's coming in a little hot I don't
know if it's because if it's just me but
yes you made a good point passion and uh
in the Bible talks about end times where
good will be
um evil evil will be good yeah and it's
crazy because we're telling women to
become better for themselves and their
family but they don't care what men
actually want it's what they want yes it
sucks and I saw Behold a pale
chlamydia followed with it yes oh my
goodness no I was gonna say that um it's
since women are more promiscuous now
than before you know one thing that I
say that people have you know it's kind
of controversial I say before you even
think about taking women seriously
nowadays need to have sex with at least
50 girls and people like whoa whoa what
are you talking about and the reason why
I say that is because if you get into a
relationship dealing with a lot of
modern women which you know where
they're racking up 10 bodies 10 20
bodies in a semester in college because
more women attend college nowadays and
you know there's I call it the
deregulated sexual Marketplace women
basically are able to hook up with
whoever they want and if you leave
limits on devices what do they do they
typically pick the best guys and they're
you know smashing a lot of these guys
and it's easy for them so for as a man
you don't want to get into a
relationship with a girl that has been
ran through and you don't you're not
able to see it I call it like basically
getting in the ring with someone who's a
black belt and you're a white belt
because you're not necessarily
experienced enough to be able to
um how do I see say this combat combat
and or identify certain characteristics
that will disqualify her from a serious
long-term relationship and guys have to
learn this skill now it used to be you
know back they won't necessarily they
won't learn the skill through sleeping
with a bunch of women though you need to
learn the skill through screening for
values and actually like finding someone
and I get that there's a lot of there's
a lot of dishonesty right and there's a
lot of deception but you know I don't
know if a guy's necessarily going to
learn like I slept with 50 women
therefore I know that you banged 14.
it's not a hard fifth
it's not a hard 50 it could be like 35
40 whatever it may be but what I am
saying is that guys need to get out
there and do a lot of girls I know this
kind of clashes with you know
traditional conservative values a lot of
times where they're like hey you know
you should be trying to be monogamous
find a woman even though I think that is
a great template maybe 50 years ago in
today's day and age with the way how
women are and how promiscuous they are
and how a lot of women sell men a dream
or they sell Purity men deal success
women deal Purity I think you need to be
able to identify women that are
promiscuous and a way to do that is by
Sleeping with them and I'll say this the
reason why it's sleeping with them
versus just Corning them and dating them
is because that's a woman's main
commodity like once you sleep with her
you've pretty much conquered that woman
not to sound crazy but you're you're
you're able to identify the games yeah
well no I but then it could also become
you know this is where we would disagree
but I think it becomes a vicious cycle
because then not wanting women to have a
high body count and you have a body
count of 50 right it makes it that's
kind of what feminism was predicated on
they go well manner doing this so we
shouldn't the truth it's not really it's
not good for anyone but I understand
what you're trying to say this is the
reality of the world we live in but
hopefully there's a hopefully there is a
split the difference law enforcement
right yeah you're in law enforcement
yeah do you ever get trained on how to
spot a fake ID uh may not have been part
of what you're doing right but no we
have like fraudulent documents yeah yeah
so anybody that's trained on how to spot
a fake ID studies the original you don't
study The Fakes because that can change
you study the original so that you can
understand and see when something is off
so I would disagree with you
wholeheartedly on this saying look if
you want to find a peer woman study what
that is go and find what that is so that
you know what to look for not
necessarily what not to look for because
I think you're going to be fooled like
you said women now will sell Purity I I
never really put it into those words but
that that makes sense right that makes
sense like I haven't been somebody who's
going out and sleeping around you need
to be able to identify the lie not
because you've been down in the mud with
them but because you have stayed out of
it here's the problem though we saw
earlier a clip of the woman talking
about her experiences right yeah with a
guy do you have sex with her no so off
rip she came in selling Purity something
like Oh I'm a good girl but from
experience if you knew who she was as a
person you'd be like hold on a second
here you're coming to Miami I gotta
paper stuff that should have been the
first sign but again most guys don't
know because they don't have the
experience yeah you need the experience
on some level yeah it's and again like I
said like is this the best way to deal
with things no no I'm a big proponent on
guys you know fighting fire and dealing
with women and in 2023 the same way they
deal with us and women I hate to say
this in the dating game nowadays they
treat men as Expendable Commodities
that's why they're able to do the things
that they do and just move on Etc
good way I tell guys to date like women
doing you treat them like Expendable
quantities as well because my thing is
this I see what you're saying like as
far as like finding a peer girl but
you're gonna have to be able to identify
the bad ones to know what a good one is
but the problem is if you do that you
will make yourself uh no longer uh an
option for the good girl she's not going
to want a guy who's done that and so now
the only woman you can end up with are
the women with the 50 body count a woman
who actually is pure is not going to
want a guy who's been with 50. I
respectfully disagree with that and I'll
tell you why women tend to find men that
can hook up with other women and have uh
sexual experience attractive now is this
all my no but women definitely don't
necessarily disqualify a man for having
sexual experiences like a man will
disqualify a woman the more experience
you are a lot of times it makes you more
attractive because uh women tend to look
for guys that are leaders Etc and if
you're a leader in the bedroom leader
and other other assets it's rarely that
a woman's going to disqualify you for
being having a promiscuous past versus
we would definitely disqualify a woman
for a promise so maybe the broader point
is shouldn't we be pushing people like
maybe the biblical prescription was the
right way to go and don't abandon it
just because it's hard it's difficult I
get it I I was single up until you know
like five years ago we thought he was
going to die yeah
he was missing a tooth no I was I used
to call him toothy yeah yeah you didn't
call me two three more than once I
didn't know he had his tooth but it was
shot out by a BB
guns for Shout Out by my cousin speaking
I'm like oh so you know about it he's
like yeah I just can't afford to fix it
right now and I want to be very clear
too that I like I think the nuclear
family is the backbone of any thriving
Society I think that's how the United
States became the world superpowers
through on the back of nuclear families
I think a man should be with one and we
should have children but unfortunately
with the way things are now where we
have this deregulated sexual marketplace
where women control everything I want to
put men in a position where they're able
to properly ascertain that woman's value
to give her that commitment because guys
don't sleep with her don't sleep here's
and I agree with you that they that they
are the minute my wife who's now my wife
at the time the girl that I was dating
when we talked about sex early and said
hey I'm waiting that immediately turns
people on or off it turns people off I'm
just interested in sex and it turns
somebody on not in a like a you know sex
way but it turns like ooh okay so this
guy has some morals this guy has a
little bit of what I'm looking for
there's some character there there's
something more than just hey I'm trying
to get in your pants there I I agree
with you like I think the problem that
we're facing is that Society you're
correct is crazy right I don't think you
play into their hand though I think you
have to go a completely different
direction well there's also another my
primary issue is before once we get
under the we get past the entry point
right here's the problem to you and your
wife and I know that and by the way we
were both very straightforward about
your quote unquote but I did want to
have sex with her before yeah of course
you did of course you did you're a man I
mean it was like it was for a while I
was like we had to we had to move the
furniture like a Great Dane's table come
on but
the reality is at this point in time not
that she ever would but now that you're
married the church has failed men in a
lot of ways here um where that woman's
talking about hey I expect this is okay
how about a prenup your wife if she
wanted to if she were that person could
leave you tomorrow and take all your
stuff even though you both waited and
that's a separate problem so there's so
many barriers to entry now where they're
going hold on a second first off body
count and then let's assume let's assume
that we all find common ground and you
each find a person who is actually uh
loyal a person who actually does value
their body and values their partner
there still is a contract right now that
doesn't make sense and men are saying
even if all that happens right I would
rather and here's another report
one-third of men between ages 18 to 24
no sexual activity at all in the
previous year a lot of them aren't even
interested in it at all that's why you
have Western men becoming what they call
Passport Bros and this is important
Urban Dictionary where they say men who
have chosen to seek out foreign women
typically from other countries for
relationships why because there's a
different standard there's a different
view of marriage There's an actual view
a contractual view of marriage they
believe according to the source that
Western women have been influenced by
cultural and societal pressures to
behave in a certain way and that by
seeking out foreign women that can find
authentic fulfilling and more harmonious
relationships they'll often go to
Southeast Asia or South America and just
because this conversation can always get
intense here's well try and guess why
it's a pleasant clip we were both vibing
in Spanglish until she spoke too fast
women who are very famous
and right now there are Western
Washington is that what you want is that
yes
I need to wait for two years two years
wow did you already apply
behind us was a church I don't know what
you guys would have done in this
situation but I'll tell you what I did
part two is coming make sure you follow
me I got good well I can guess now
here's the thing women are like is that
what you want do you think yes oh you
mean someone someone who is pretty who
seems happy to be there who's nice who's
happy to be in a relationship and if he
is the primary earner she's glad to
support me yep look here's the thing men
have not changed what they want in women
women have changed what they expect from
men now this is not good for women what
women used to want was someone who could
protect and provide for them I mean let
me give you an example here
uh Winston Churchill and uh you can
really uh Gary from Russia we're gonna
have him in later we have an
intervention with him because he keeps
picking the wrong woman yeah we're gonna
try to help so a lot of women right they
want men who can provide and protect
okay that's important now also you need
to be tender right to your wife you need
to love you of course all those things
Winston Churchill is a good example A
lot of people want their wartime leaders
and then when it's not wartime they want
to put them back on the shelf and say
okay we want to do it so Winston
Churchill right we had Chamberlain or
the Nazis they were moving moving
forward down the Western Front and uh
they said hey we need someone we need a
we need a hard ass we need Winston
Churchill right brought him in almost
single-handedly kind of put a pause on
the Nazi rides which allowed America to
get in and save the rest of the world
you're welcome sorry we were a little
late but did you guys know Churchill was
ousted two years later did you know that
not surprised two years later why
because he didn't support socialized
Healthcare
so they said we need someone to come in
and protect us and then afterwards he
was saying well I said you'll become a
bunch of lazy socialist and
they're like okay now we don't want you
anymore because we we don't need you
it's not wartime it's peace so now we
want all the free stuff and he said but
there could be wartime it could come
again it doesn't matter they got rid of
them you see that a lot in relationships
where they want someone who's going
going to go out and protect and provide
okay but also is sensitive also does all
of these new things that men weren't
required to do now I get I'm not saying
that men should just come home put their
feet up and not contribute at all but
men still want the same thing I'm
telling you it's women if you are if
you're looking to to find a man if you
were saying Hey how do I make myself
desirable to a man they want a woman
who's yeah pretty yeah but they want a
woman who's nice
they want a woman who they feel like
they come home and it's a safe haven and
someone who they can trust someone who
has their back we mock it no I'm not
just going to be some Tammy Wynette
Stand By Your Man well then don't expect
to find a man men still want the same
things women want a man who can provide
protect also be sensitive also listen to
the problems about Karen look
I I'd call this the 99 and 99 rule okay
and I will have this and I've discussed
this before but maybe this might be new
to you guys I'll ask people who are
married a couple I was okay you're
married and this is your husband it's
okay something goes bump in the night
is he expected to go down and take care
of it and the woman invariably says yes
and if you're at home right now answer
these questions does he go down or do
you go down say hey hubby lock the door
no he is okay does he work
does he provide you I'm not asking if
he's Rich does he work does he provide
for you okay I've now crossed a
threshold but I'm going to ask you one
more question does he ever do anything
nice for you like flowers or anything
sense okay congratulations you are now
with a man who is doing more than 99 of
men
ever since the beginning of time
especially if he listens to you discuss
problems that have no effect on him no
one in the nomadic days or if you go
back to you go back to any ancient
civilization was that expected of men
then you ask women okay so flip side do
you cook every day no you're doing less
than 99 of women since the beginning of
time now you may not want to cook you
may not but guess what he still wants
that he still wants a woman to be to be
there to support him and I understand
you can both share responsibilities and
you both work but the expectations of
men have changed so much and the desires
of men that they have and women have not
changed that's why you see things like
the right we've talked about uh passport
Bros sex dolls this is an ex-google
Chief said that AI sex dolls will quote
redesign love and relationships the
global market in 2020 was 411 million
dollars when it's expected to grow by 56
percent and by the way there was a
survey 50 of sex doll users consider
their doll as quote the ideal partner
for me and I feel emotionally attached
to it like this guy this will be her
anniversary present for our 10-year I
got these uh matching wedding bands they
say synthetic love lasts forever on them
which one's the robot now here's the
thing I
I'm not gonna lie to you I decided to
test it out for research purposes uh and
in my case I think I deserve my money
back wait Tesla
[Applause]
hey it's the lemon it's the lemon law
but you know what it's the last time I
take a tip on a on an Electronics
purchase from from Gerald me yeah you
know Bianca's um
a missionary
what was the missionary right sorry
because she was raised by another
[Laughter]
I was really scared
wait what test what by the way the
scariest part is that some of those sex
dolls they're like their only ipx3
they're just slightly walked through
they're just slightly water resistant
yeah you don't want to read the reviews
either
um this is all really interesting
because like we talked about some of the
root causes of you know what's going on
here and now we're dealing with some of
the adaptations that men are kind of the
consequences yeah of what they're doing
you know whether it's passport Bros sex
dolls uh we're just being lonely the
more men are lonely than ever before
that too video games uh we also we we
had a podcast we talked about like the
rise of virtual reality now where a lot
of guys are using that and I would say
if you're a betting guy or you know you
want to invest in something I think
investing in sex dolls and all this
stuff in the future is definitely going
to be a good thing because the problem
is this well maybe not a good thing
financially wise yeah you financially
yeah I'm saying investing to make
because I predict that it's going to
continue to grow as well go in second
that's not license with sex dolls to go
and make deposits yeah sure but I but I
will say that what's what's basically
happened we showed this clip earlier is
that women have changed but they still
expect men to be traditional when the
women don't necessarily provide
traditional value back they want a guy
who's going to be a protector a provider
do all these things that men
historically have done while
simultaneously not bringing back what
men required of women they're
they don't necessarily want to cook they
don't want to clean they don't want to
obey you they don't want to be
submissive they want to be able to
behave however they want while
simultaneously getting guy and that's
the equivalent to me being a fat nacho
cheese eating loser playing video games
all the time saying I deserve a bad
it's ridiculous but it's
interesting just to be clear because
you're black bad is a good thing
yes yes sorry yes
I think that's a bad fish that
cringe I might just go on a date and
she's like I'm a bad she's like we
just said that out loud oh yeah and
here's other things don't call me bossy
one thing and I want to watch you guys
to really like this is the thing that's
crazy right so we've interviewed like
almost 3 000 chicks on our show and we
always ask them what do you want in a
man and they always provide the same
things that we talked about you know and
then some all the other things like
insensitive and flowers and it's like
okay now it's you want Superman then
this is what I asked them what do you
think that man wants back in return and
then you know what they say it's
incredible to me they say oh they want a
boss they want someone who can like make
money just like that yeah I know I'm
like holy crap they literally list off
all the things that um they want in a
man yeah and I was like Wow and it's
amazing billionaires marry waitresses
dude they don't care yeah and then
that's when it hit me women don't give a
what we want no they only care
about what they want a lot of yes right
now the modern woman who's been a
majority Yes again by the way to women
up there are plenty of women out there
who are not but this is not for you and
here's the thing just like just like if
people it was never as just to be clear
it was never as ubiquitous as people
said like domestic abuse for men by the
way the term whipping post a lot of
people don't know this that came from
society
it was exclusively for men who beat
their wives you were tied to a whipping
post and you were embarrassed in the
Town Square because domestic abuse has
always been considered horrible just to
be clear so what I'm saying is men
needed to clear ranks they need to clean
ranks at some point in women they're I
get that this is not all but there
aren't enough of you speaking out
because by the way men are more lonely
than ever but women are miserable too
studies show that women are unhappier
than ever 20 of women under the age of
40 are an antidepressant yes okay this
and this increases by the way the closer
they get to menopause and I don't
necessarily know that we have the
numbers after menopause but again when
you ask 60 year old women if you ask 60
70 year old men 80 year old men like hey
what would you what do you wish that you
had done more it hasn't been the same
this is where men and women find Common
Ground time with family time with family
you know what's crazy you're brought up
um medication right so there's a test
that guy's doing nowadays well actually
the players they go to a girl's crib
look in the medicine cabinet and they
see any medication in there yeah and
that's a huge rate of flight because
either they're in therapy and they need
that that's a red flag because guess
what in your relationship move forward
that might be a problem so it's just
tough and it's interesting as they
become more and more liberated they've
been they've had more anxiety more
Depression more sadness more
miserableness it's crazy because like
I've always said like feminism was a lie
to women they they told them go get a
career make this money become successful
Etc but what they don't realize is
woman's sexual market value is
absolutely perishable you only have a
finite amount of time to get the guy
that you want and the older you get the
more money you make the more you dwindle
that pool of man and you're becoming
less attractive to those very men that
you want yeah no I think you're
absolutely right well no and so we had
that clip earlier about that girl saying
I want all these conservative values
yeah yeah liberal right yeah that was
that whole thing like I want you do you
see like what you're saying there you
want all of these things that maybe in
your teen late teens early 20s didn't
really care about those things you're
like ooh that's gross I'm going to be an
independent woman I'm gonna go get these
things and then you're like wait a
minute
I kind of do want those things but
here's the thing I don't want to change
anything about what I'm doing I want to
just be crazy liberal but I want all
these conservative values that is the
misalignment like you cannot have both
because these things live within kind of
the conservative ideal outside of it you
get to all the beta males you want but
apparently that's not satisfying you
right now and women are miserable
because like I have never seen more
positive change in people's lives and
couples that I've known than when they
had children both in men and women but
it gives this fulfillment this value of
like purpose in life and it's not the
only one my wife is an amazing
phenomenally gifted person who's going
to go back to work at some point so that
our kids can see Mom is a badass as well
right but she has chosen to do what
she's doing at home because it is that
important and that fulfilling and people
that skate on that and people that get
too old for that because they've chased
down every lie that's out there end up
missing out and not only on that this is
going to sound old but once you start
having kids and you enjoy that process
and then you see the joy that it brings
your parents you experience this yeah
the joy that it brings them I don't know
that I'll get that my dad finally
started talking to me I know yeah it's
crazy right you had kids and all of a
sudden you're important again my mom
face Palms me she's like yeah where's my
grandchildren and so there's these
benefits there are these things that are
built in that you miss yeah really big
important things societally that make
life more full and Rich and you guys are
missing this because you're chasing
after I'm sorry we talked about this
yesterday in the five minute joke you're
chasing after fleeting
Joy has any of this made your life
better men or women this is the thing
and often men are told they can't speak
speak about it because you're not a
woman right no no uh no vagina no
opinion but now the trans thing like no
uterus no pain I don't know just
whatever if you have a moo moo I guess
you qualify but this is the issue hasn't
made your life any better that's the
important thing that we need to ask
ourselves right now has this made
relationships better has it made your
life better and I will say this you know
one time I was talking with someone who
was
conservative a woman who was kind of a
feminist and didn't realize it and I
tell the story all the time uh because
feminists say you can have it all right
they say you can work and you can be a
stay-at-home mom and then you have
conservative women and they're mostly
right but she was really upset she said
you know that's the LIE of feminism
should you know you can have it all you
don't should you have to make a choice
and choose your lips she said you know
you can't be a professional woman out
there working in BS you do have to make
a choice and I said huh that must be
wonderful to have a choice
she said what I said so you're saying
that when you were young your parents
said hey if you want to be a
professional working woman you can do
that she said yes it or you know you can
also be a mom and be a great wife yeah I
said do you realize that no young man
has ever had that discussion any young
man who has show of hands any man when
he realized that he thought women were
pretty and he wanted to have his own
real live naked lady at home one day
anyone anyone ever have your mom or your
dad say well the good news is you have a
choice you can be a working man and
provide or you can be a stay-at-home dad
nope never must be nice to have a choice
and by the way even if you tried to make
it societally acceptable for men have a
choice they wouldn't take it because men
have to keep themselves accountable and
men don't respect other men and they
know that women ultimately no matter
what you say or do they won't respect
men who don't try and you don't have to
by the way to be clear I'm not saying
you have to be CEO of a Fortune 500
company you could be a garbage man
used to be valuable that hey a man is
going out and a man is providing for
this person but it Not only was valuable
it was a prerequisite so feminism is a
lie that you can have it all
the truth is that there does need to be
a choice made and the truth is only one
of the two Sexes and there are only two
has that choice
and that choice by the way
it has a finite amount of time there is
a shelf life and we'll talk more about
that as we continue and you know what I
think is right here is we can agree on
the con the root causes yeah and then
disagree on some of the approaches or
Solutions hey look at that we're not a
bunch of liberal sticks
um
we're gonna go to muglier but I want
people to know where they can find you
before we go fresh and fit again another
pleasure check us out on Rumble and
YouTube man you know Rumble is the
future we love Rumble shout out to Chris
Shout out to you know stand up for free
speech uh rumble.com fresher fit check
us out on YouTube as well and uh yeah
YouTube absolutely wants to memory hole
you worse than the runner chick so hey
if you're watching right now on YouTube
uh well there's nothing you can do if
you're watching on Rumble click that
button right there and you can uh join
my club at 69 annually get Nick depalo
this show every day we're gonna do
another give us 89 sorry sorry sorry
false advertising I was thinking of
Gordon Lydia selling gold for bill today
um and by the way if you have
mesothelioma I can't help you you're
going to die so 89 annually get nicked
Apollo every day you get twice the show
uh you get Brian Cowan show Hodgetwins
Show starting this month Alex Jones
every Friday guns in gear and of course
you support an undercover unit click
that button are you about to say
something there oh what oh yeah by the
way we've been holding back this whole
show so we're gonna turn up on Monday
right now we're holding it back man you
guys are gonna get unfiltered unhinged
stuff on Mud Club right now it doesn't
matter they're black guys so they can
say all the racial episodes they want
let's go I have to Tamp it down Rumble
thank you YouTube piss off yeah
foreign
[Applause]